I don't think my religion lets me be
friends with people like you probably
when I was told that my mom had passed
away when I was a kid my mom said I
should have aborted you it's kind of
touchy now because of the whole abortion
that's going on but my mom when I was a
kid my mom said I should have aborted
you
I guess it's hurtful now because
obviously I'm alive and it just makes me
feel like I shouldn't have been alive
but yeah that's most people think that's
been said to me it was in the middle of
the night I got woken up by a police
officer that came to my house knocked on
the door they were very nice about it
but um it was a bit of a shock and you
know you never really get over that it
was only two years ago so I was 15 I
feel like I I took it as well as I could
I was probably a little immature about
it but it's not like you can be
experienced at that you just take it how
you can you know when my mom told me she
loved me that her mom said that t you
know just maybe said
I got sent away by my parents when I was
16
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
you want me to give you a minute I don't
even know what like
I'm just I don't even know what like the
most painful part of it was
[Music]
this is hard to find like a short way to
say so basically there was a lot of
issues like within my family just kind
of a lot of lack of communication and
things were hard and I didn't I never
really kind of got along with my family
and I was always coming pushed to the
side and
I kind of grew up by myself and
went and did my own thing and my parents
couldn't really see it I never bothered
to really see it or ask about it I guess
and it was just their interpretation for
us mine and yeah I think were hard and
they weren't working you know I was
gonna go move out and live with my
sister I'm not three I'm like before my
flight like these two people two people
about our number to see you move warm
nice walking in Laramie they just
dragged me on my house
[Music]
took me to Oregon where I spent three
months in the woods
[Music]
the next year and a half in Montana
there's just nothing I can do about it
it's Colorado
wilderness treatment program I don't
even really know and then I have to care
I was at Montana Academy it's like
there's like a series of therapeutic
boarding schools you get your rights
back once you turn 18 there's literally
nothing you can do like there's there's
nothing and like like it only gets worse
if you resist you know so like lockdown
facilities
I had friends that were like we sent out
of the country you know where you don't
turn like the legal age tell your 25 you
know you're just forced to like clean
and do Drudge work for for free I mean
everybody's experience is different
before
I was taught
and I really had to like mourn the loss
of my family and
[Music]
it's hard not to like be able to trust
your family
like your own parents
[Music]
I'm about to be 21 which is great
because it all feels like yesterday
like not a day goes by that I don't
think about it feel affected by it in
one way or another
[Music]
do you have anything like an escape from
it is there anything that you're doing
now music first shirt I love music
[Music]
any moment I can't I'm making music
how would you describe your music I
don't know my music doesn't necessarily
have a genre I think that's the most
important part about it
it's not confined to one you know
specific thing but if I had to call it
anything I'd call it alternative hip-hop
hopefully my father's will check out
your music because I'm personally really
curious to hear I'm sure they will be
too and thank you so much for doing this
I know it was tough for you but I think
it just shows like how strong you are
that you were able to talk about it and
I feel like you're gonna do a lot of
beautiful things the most painful thing
I've been told it was that my daughter's
brain cancer she's now in the hospital
and I'm trying to deal with that right
now yes that my parents lost custody of
me my my dad was the pastor but he was
also kind of a piece so he did some
stupid I don't know he wasn't he wasn't
one of those like legit pastors like the
flu shaped like fake ones he he'd on
trouble with the law and then my mom
didn't really do much so
nice they lost custody of me I mean I'm
bossy I don't like that you never call a
guy boss he always called female bossy
you know I don't like that you remember
who said it my mom it made me feel bossy
it made me feel like I insert myself too
often I think that powerful women
oftentimes get shut down
and whether it's blatantly or not you
know you would never think to call him
man boss you know he's he's forward or
he's a leader he's not bossy but females
are when I was little I was called a
Bordeaux cabochon and that means it's a
jacket but at the same time it's kind of
like you have a big head and you've done
there we go yeah that that would be and
that was taught by one of my my teachers
in third grade my mom tells me I came
home crying after that yeah I think that
one had affected my school career for
the rest of my life
yeah the most painful thing I told me in
my was told in my whole life was that I
was the sad excuse for a brother my mom
said it to me broke my heart I was in
high school I was 17 at the time it
crushed me I am a failure as a father
for dessert a he doesn't know how to
have kids anymore go kill yourself
probably your dad doesn't think that you
should have two dads so he doesn't want
to ever see you again
I still cry about it I cheated on you
for sure
that was like the most painful face why
I never told him
how'd you react I like I don't know
we're crazy
what but me obviously you go from from
stuff in the past so when I was like in
eighth grade the guy that I liked called
me like a fat pig and um ever since then
I've been very like uncomfortable with
my weight and at the same time I was
going through like the beginning stages
of like developing an eating disorder so
it like perfect timing I guess but um
yeah so it was like it I've grown past
that and learned that like my body is
the way it is and if you don't like it
that's for you yeah back when I was in
elementary school I was I guess I grew
up kind of poor so and I had like one
coat and I wore that for about three or
four years and then I try to talk to
this girl and she said sorry I can't
talk to you until you get a new coat so
I was hoping for Christmas that I got a
new coat but I didn't so I never talked
to the girl but I'm older now and I'm
over it there's this guy and I want to
say it was freshman year of high school
he called me a beluga well that was
probably the most painful thing I was
really uncomfortable because I didn't
know what my response gonna be and he
said to pretty much say whatever I want
to say about him but I just didn't want
to think like two wrongs made right you
know I'm rigid lots of people I could
think of one person in particular you
know when things strike you when they're
true they kind of work into your heart
center and then they go pink because
it's true and so I felt hurt offended
and found out
my son told me that I missed out on his
birthday again for the second date which
is only like half a day excited go to
work in the morning but even feeling
that guilt of not being everybody while
the previous one but all the other seven
I was there you know it's just that one
all of a sudden it's the biggest job in
the world to be a role model
so being somebody that this person looks
up to and install of a sunny or
something I'm like are you letting
somebody down like big time you know and
it's not a big deal compared to what a
lot of uh people been through but for me
it is yeah
most people think every totally but the
doctor saying that I have cancer I knew
how to handle it
I was like okay take a deep breath it's
gonna be alright and I'm a cancer
survivor
yeh so I gotta say that no matter what
you've been told you just gotta keep
your head up
keep fighting and
when you sleep on the water you'd like
you don't know how to sleep but you wait
you look for your way out no matter what
situation it thanks for watching another
episode basically I just want to say
welcome to the new subscribers and to
the subscribers who have been with me
for a while I want to thank you for
constantly supporting my channel and to
the new viewers who haven't subscribe to
my channel yet I hope you get to the
point where you want to hit the
subscribe button and possibly the ball
next to it so you get notified every
time I put up in your episode I think
that's pretty much it thank you guys
again for everything
and I'll see you next week